all right thank you all so much for
joining us
i'm susan wilson a producer for the
center for art science and technology
as everyone knows the pandemic has
thrown all of us into a sudden
dependence on virtual events we're all
working together on navigating this new
world and
getting through all the challenges and
opportunities that it provides as we all
continue to iterate on the best
practices for online events we've begun
to transition now from simply trying to
recreate and replace traditional events
to really taking advantage of a virtual
format
to combine the liveness and
collaboration that you can find in
person with the technological and
locationally boundless benefits of
virtuality
and i'm so pleased to introduce chandra
ray and peter goddard who will be
sharing their experiences and their own
best practices for virtual events with
us today
deandra is a 2015 graduate of mit in
course four she's an architectural
designer educator and advocate for
restorative justice
peter graduated from mit in 2015 with
degrees in mechanical and electrical
engineering and is currently pursuing a
phd in mechanical engineering
looking at ways to use aluminum waste to
power desalinization and produce energy
he's also a jazz pianist and composer
together they co-organized space for
action rebuilding a sustainable world
a 90-minute performance conversation in
april that brought together leading
musicians
scientists politicians and activists to
reflect on how the pandemic is reshaping
our relationship with the earth
we're really excited to have them with
us today to share some of their insights
from creating space for action and other
virtual events
and with that i'll turn it over to peter
and tianka i
am teandra ray that is peter goddard
thank you for the beautiful introduction
susan
um we are two mit alum and now peter is
back
in the mit student role um who are
currently spearheading this collective
called space reaction and it's a group
of
interdisciplinary folks so we have
artists we have
educators we have musicians scientists
um activists people from the boston
community and a lot of people from the
mit community who are coming
together to curate events and exhibits
that help the public process the
large issue of our time which is climate
change
and how that affects our relationships
with each other our relationships with
the earth
how it intersects with various social
justice issues
and disproportionately affects people
of color in our country america
specifically
so we've had a lot of success with
events
in the virtual realm we actually didn't
set out
um as a virtual organization
we we had plans to actually hold a large
event and installation at mit
this past spring for earth day and of
course as the pandemic hit
things shifted a little bit so we had a
few
virtual concerts conversations
talks all mixed together these virtual
experiences
um over the course of the past several
months
and peter is going to show us a little
bit
from our performance event and
we had speakers from all over we had um
reverend mariama white hammond who is a
local minister and climate activist in
the boston area we had
representative ayanna presley there we
had bill mckibben
um and we had esperanza spalding which
was really exciting so she did some
music some
um speaking and we also brought in
some mit alum and some berkeley's um
professors and alum to do some original
compositions
so peter do you want to show us those
clips
yeah and before i do um so to accomplish
all that tantra said
that we're trying to accomplish as an
organization space for action
uh the most important thing for us are
holding these events these engaging
events
where it's a conversation and it's also
educational
and so we spent a lot of time thinking
about how to accomplish this
in a virtual setting and so what i'm
about to show you
is some clips uh from our most recent
event
and so what i want you to look out for
is just the diversity in terms of
content
and in terms of communities that we're
engaging with uh as well as
how sort of the talks and performances
flow
and um transition from from one into the
other
and note that there there was a uh
breakout session in here that that i
will not be showing
but aside from that just
take it all in and try to take some
notes we'll discuss this after
i show you
[Music]
come together
oh parts of
me
scattered and carried by wind and
waves
two distant lands
let us remember
[Music]
that wholeness
[Music]
we will now hear from edmar cologne and
tutti jurian
edmar is a saxophonist pianist and
composer from puerto rico
who is currently on the faculty of the
berkeley college of music
tutti is the singer songwriter actor and
voice over artist
and they have both performed worldwide
today they will be
performing somewhere over the rainbow so
it is my pleasure
to introduce my dear friends tutti and
edmar
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
good evening i say to you recognizing
that for some of us
this actually is a statement of faith to
say that it is a good
evening means to imagine
and let go of some of the anxiety that
we feel
we have an opportunity here an
obligation
to build a more equitable future and i'm
so grateful for
all of you frontliners you community
builders
uh to be your sister in solidarity and
actualizing that vision and for those
that don't get it
i have great confidence and your powers
of persuasion and influence and
storytelling to bring others along thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
our next special guest is a true force
of nature that since the inception of
her career has been propelling her field
forward
with mighty speed and depth while
inspiring many to explore their highest
potential
as artists and human beings please help
me virtually welcome grammar winning
artists and big advocate
for a climate and natural environment
and
paraphrasing from reverend mariama's
words okay i get to call her my dear
friend my sister
esperanza spaulding
i'm out the house of worship right for
pride right for doctrine rightful sin
on my laptop for devices where i shop
for wisdom
at my very fingertips so much more than
some holy men could ever hope to
comprehend so maybe now the holy spirit
is simply a body network
anchored and accumulated knowledge now
encompassing the globe
be like the drum loud and sure
[Music]
feel the life rush through our veins
cool and pure
now the oneness of our spirit
shall endure
say oh yeah oh yeah
come on
oh man it was really hard to stop a lot
of those clips
but so that was uh just a couple
snippets um if you would like to see the
whole thing in full it's up on youtube
i'm happy to share that with you
um you'll get our contact information at
the end of this presentation
but to make this engaging um we're
hoping that for this next part if you're
able
that you uh we're gonna send you all
into breakout rooms and we hope that if
you're able
you can uh share your video and unmute
yourselves
and uh in groups of i think about five
or so
we would like you to answer these two
questions talk about these two questions
for about 10 minutes or so and then
we'll reconvene and
discuss and try to coalesce your
responses
all right welcome back everybody so
now we are going to
talk about these questions as a group
and just
if we'll call on a couple of
representatives from each
breakout room to discuss
some insights that you came up with and
we're going to use this uh
jamboard to document some of these
responses
so uh i know stacy you're taking some
notes i'm gonna cold call on you to
maybe
kick us off yeah sure i did take some
notes um so we
talked about first what makes an
in-person event so special
um that we talked about how you can see
people more and you get
more non-verbal cues um
i did mention that at mit there's
usually snacks and beverages
which is a plus there's a networking
aspect and it feels a little bit more
collegial
multiple people can be talking or
discussing something at the same time
and you can move around the physical
space instead of sitting in front of a
screen which i think helps a little bit
with event fatigue
um and then moving into successful
versus on
unsuccessful online events we talked a
lot about
practicing and rehearsing and making
sure that your presenters understand the
technology
having a really professional run sheet
and tech backups
and the more free free form things are
the more stressful they can become
we also talked about how it's really
important to understand the attention
span of most people you can't really
have an
hour lecture in zoom um and with that we
wanted to
provide an opportunity for people to
interact and we noted that breakout
rooms are really effective for that
um we've had some success across
multiple different departments with
different types of icebreaker or games
where people get to know each other and
interact a little bit
and then we talked about how if you're
kind of planning your run of show if you
have something a little surprising and
something kind of engaging and then
other discussion points you can have an
actually a really engaging meeting
so those were our uh points
great marion or shannon rose anything to
add
you were also in the room nope that was
a pretty comprehensive
representation thanks stacy thank you
cool so anyone from the other room would
you like to
share some insights as to these two
questions
i was nominated so i will share our
insights
excellent room number two um we had a
lot of overlap in what was discussed
just now um i would say successful
in-person events
some things that we discussed that have
not yet been mentioned
are the cultivation of atmosphere
and in-person events and what an impact
that makes on your experience
as an audience um we also talked we
talked a little bit about
like other people generally but i would
classify rather than networking what we
talked about more as intimacy
like noticing other things that other
people are saying reacting
to stimulus like with other people
having conversations that are
spontaneous and
spontaneity is like another successful
in-person event trademark i think the
ability to
be spontaneous in the conversation that
you're having
um in direct opposition to that it was
heidi that mentioned how
successful virtual events need to have
some sort of a moderator
or agenda if everyone's talking at once
and it's sort of a free-for-all it's
really difficult to have a meaningful
conversation because you literally
cannot hear each other speak
because the audio won't take multiple
inputs at the same time
um i personally just find it really hard
to have conversations on zoom for that
reason because
so much of my conversation style is like
you know spitballing so i find it really
hard to talk to people on
zoom the way that i would normally speak
um
another element of successful virtual
events that we talked about was
um interactivity which
stacy mentioned we were talking about
how having an
interactive element makes it easier to
kind of pay attention
and feel engaged in the online meeting
that you're in
which can be really nice um
i think that that's pretty much
everything that diverged from
what stacy mentioned am i missing
anything maybe heidi or lydia could
chime in or catherine
and the spontaneity part i would just
add um
we talked about running into people
which is harder to do
when you're on zoom just the spontaneity
of being out and about it like a boston
theater performance and seeing someone
you know
well or someone you don't know well but
i guess it happens sometimes on soon but
not as much
totally well i'm i'm super impressed
that you all are experts
on uh virtual events it seems at least
you've been to enough
good and bad ones to to know the
difference
so i'm just gonna try to you know you
you've all touched on all of these
things
um that i'm about to tell you but
our philosophy with with our event which
you know we got good feedback on
um and i i tried to distill a lot of the
feedback
that we'd received and it was very much
in line with what we were all discussing
here
but to kind of distill those into three
guiding principles
um we would put them into these three
categories brevity
keep things short keep things moving as
you all mentioned
the tension spans are low especially
when you're staring at a screen you're
not
up and about and moving around and so
it's best to avoid
long lectures wherever possible with
with only a couple speakers
so if you are going to be introducing a
lot of spoken
or verbal content it's good to either
switch back and forth between people or
just have as many speakers as possible
the second guiding principle would be
diversity so it's
super important to include varied
content and also varied representation
from different groups and continuity
actually back on that middle point real
quick the representation from different
groups is
is key because you know different people
are going to be
different speakers are going to be
engaging to different groups of people
and so
you want to have content for everyone
that you expect to be on the call and
maybe even some people you don't expect
and then the third point is continuity
so no matter what you're doing like try
to tell a story
maintain a clear theme and the
transitions in particular
are key
and a couple zoom tips and again these
are all basically things that people
mentioned
we found that it was really good to
avoid sort of the webinar style events
where there's this extra layer of
anonymity where you can't even
see the people who are on the call it's
nice to have
you know names and faces and especially
as a performer it's really nice to look
out
to your zoom screen and kind of imagine
an audience and you can seeing all the
the squares is actually very inspiring
to a performer
have a script and practice the
transitions including sharing screen
we've all been on
these zoom meetings where people don't
know how to share their screen or unmute
themselves
etc mistakes obviously happen but just
you know
try to try to be prepared there um
frequent use of breakout rooms and just
encouraging people to show video and
keeping them engaged at various points
throughout
obviously is great idea for musicians
it's extremely important to
set up the audio correctly so there are
all these advanced audio settings that
turn off the zoom algorithms which try
to make
which are optimized for speech and
there's in particular this option called
turn on original sound which just takes
your raw input from the microphone which
is great for
for live instruments as someone
mentioned
in in our group at least it's important
to have a moderator
in any large group discussions um people
can't be trusted to sort of
self-organize when there's
you know 20 or so people people are
going to talk over one another
and then sort of the best case scenario
is everyone's just silent
so it's good to break it up into smaller
groups or if it is a larger group
obviously
have a moderator using a team and
spreading out responsibilities
is extremely helpful and you can have
someone managing breakout rooms
someone speaking and someone um
you know sitting idle ready to unmute
the uh
the person who forgot to mute themselves
and is yelling
at their dog which literally happened to
us um
and uh in general just be positive and
embrace the format
you know it's obviously it's not a live
event and
i think there are some benefits to doing
uh
virtual events so just try to embrace
those benefits and by the way i will be
sharing these slides so
you don't feel like you have to take um
notes on all of this i'd be happy happy
to share this afterwards
so tanda do you want to talk about some
things that aren't zoom which are pretty
cool
yes so we all know
and love zoom at this point or well
complicate a relationship with zoom
maybe but
we all have interacted with this format
and are interacting with it now but
there are definitely ways to enhance the
zoom experience
by adding in elements that go beyond
just the
video and just to give you a little
preview of what
peter and i have been cooking up with
the sfa team we're thinking about
in physical installations that are
interactive via a web stream
or interactive um from afar
and thinking about how we organize
people in outdoor spaces but streaming
it so that it
is accessible to people who cannot
access the outdoor spaces and again
different ways of interactivity
um virtually that is not just
us having a conversation and interacting
with physical
built space which is really interesting
but i want to point out a couple
of other tools that we've interacted
with in the last few months
um so high fidelity is an interesting
tool
i think it was heidi that mentioned in
our group
um enjoying like just bumping into
people and being able to hear a
conversation from afar
so what high fidelity does um is
it it places everybody on a map that
you design like a map of a space and
it's a 2d map
um and peter you could click on that
link i
think not the picture the the caption
and takes you to that page so you're
actually just a
a floating head on this map and you
actually hear
in your headphones the people talking
around you depending on where your icon
is on the map so peter and i attended
this like
birthday party festival thing um
where they used this and it was pretty
interesting um there are definitely some
kinks to work out in terms of like not
being awkward
but when you're with friends i think it
especially is helpful when you're with a
group of people that you
already have some familiarity with but
the points on the map can be linked to
different things so we talked about
whether you could link a portion of the
map to a zoom meeting so you go to like
kind of a mini breakout room and
just interesting things like that they
mapped it to a series of google photos
um from different past events
to make people feel nostalgic and hid a
scavenger hunt inside of there so there
are lots of different options
um for interaction there and then there
are tools like mirror boards or the
jamboard that you just saw
which are great for collaborative
brainstorming
and of course there's the whatever you
all
decide to come up with um in your your
innovative
creative capacities so we want to have a
quick
second breakout session and i'll post
the
questions in the chat where we take some
time to actually brainstorm think about
what
we can do with what we have and specific
to
all of your fields and spheres of
influence and communities
and preferences here at mit and actually
in the spirit of improvisation and
adapting to time constraints
we're actually not going to break out
we're just going to have this discussion
amongst us so if you want to uh
turn on your cameras right now um we'll
just have this discussion
straight up so if you want to speak just
because there's a few more of us than in
previous breakout rooms either raise
your hand physically
or use the raised hand feature and i'll
i'll just call and you'll facilitate
and the questions are in the chat so
peter you can take that off the screen
if you want so we can see each other
all right so
question one what types of events do you
imagine organizing this semester and
what do they encompass so are you
thinking audio visual conversation music
etc
um i'll go i am going to be doing all of
that
i oversee the arts scholars and the grad
arts forum
and the creative arts competition so i'm
going to be doing
virtual gallery tours virtual live
streamed concerts with
zoom talkbacks um including conversation
i'm gonna be doing
you know um workshop style classes on
business fundamentals i'm gonna be doing
a pitch finale event that's sort of like
shark tank um i'm pretty much gonna be
doing anything that you can imagine
encompassing you know non-curricular
education
and trying to replicate some modicum of
a shared musical or arts experience with
conversation
love it doing it all right uh marion
marion i saw your hand up
yes so i'm with the program at art
culture
and technology and we're gonna have our
lecture series online and i was
very interested in the in the
non-webinar
uh component because the thing that
we're being sold on
is that when you do it virtually you can
have thousands of people i mean
or at least hundreds of people so so
we're kind of
it looks like we're tiptoeing towards
the webinar style
but that won't really facilitate the
kind of engagement
although many would argue that there
isn't much engagement at our lecture
series but you didn't hear that from me
um so so i would be very curious to hear
about what your suggestions are
great susan
i just want to do really quickly i mean
one of the things that i found really
powerful about the space for action
thing in the
uh in the spring was that we did have
the full audience i think one of the
things that i was talking about with the
student in our sort of breakout group
was you you lose that energy
in zoom between a performer and the
audience member and i think that that
really affects performers and i think as
an audience member
we just kind of check out more easily
because we're used to being a little bit
visible
in an audience space like if you fall
asleep you eventually feel embarrassed
usually you know like i mean there's
there's a bit more
responsibility to the moment um and what
i really loved about the end of that
section especially where there was so
much
community discussion and engagement with
the sort of song and the spirit of the
whole thing is that
we did have you know everybody on camera
i mean most people were on camera the
whole time
and and it was really powerful to be
able to scroll through and just see
people
experiencing the same thing that you
were and and i recall hearing from the
artists involved in that piece as well
that it made a difference to see people
watching you
um as opposed to just kind of like
looking at your own self and the camera
the whole time
and i think i think those things really
were really powerful and made a big
difference it was like a small thing
that i think had a huge impact
right we spent so much time thinking
about what would engage our audience but
it's also important to engage
the speakers and the performers as well
and and
like susan said like the the quality of
the performance
goes way up when when people feel that
pressure
um and that support so
any any last thoughts uh anyone else
planning event or had some new ideas for
some events they would like to see even
i this is not a specific event that i'm
planning but i am
always thinking about ways to make
events that
combine as dana was talking about in our
breakout room
um some sort of gathering but also
a lot of interactive parts and games so
not necessary somewhere in between like
a group of friends getting together to
play a game
and a live stream of performance i think
there would be a really
cool niche in the middle there which i
you guys achieved with the space for
action event
um but this idea of incorporating both
interactivity and
performance in the same space no
specific ideas for that but i
um have been brainstorming a little bit
i love it let's make it happen
any last thoughts that at this point we
could also just open it up to general
questions
you might have for us about our space
for action events or
how we're thinking about things these
days before i also want to give huge
shout out to susan
and heidi for the space reaction event
they they both
contributed a lot of content so it's so
happy to see you here and
it's awesome that you helped make uh
make it what it was it's
really cool so any any last thoughts
here i know we're kind of bumping up on
our time but
i have a great question actually yeah um
how much of the space for action
content was pre-recorded versus live
it was 100 live 100 live amazing
zero recording yeah risky
especially that first piece which we
kind of slipped in
last minute to have the drum
and beats coming from one place and
peter turning on the piano from another
place and ricky's singing so
i'd encourage from that for everyone to
experiment
push the boundaries um you don't have to
be afraid of
the lag um as musicians like you can
make it
i mean there are definitely certain
things you can't do but
get creative and innovative with it
and i think marion you were talking
about the lecture series and
creating something that's more engaging
well maybe
that means that you reimagine the
lecture series and it's no longer just a
lecture but it's
more of an interactive conversation and
it's not
just a person speaking and then q a but
maybe that's something that weaves
differently um if people are open to
actually pushing that boundary at this
point
that is the question
and i will say we had a lot of a great
idea
you know we had people like bill
mckibben esperanza spalding rep
ayanna presley and you know people
really felt like they were
on a zoom call with these people because
they literally were they felt like that
you were in a very small room is very
intimate with these
just like incredible people you you
would not have access to in any other
setting
um and you know we could have that we
could have definitely asked for
pre-recorded input from from each of
these
artists and speakers but we really
didn't want that we we took the risk and
just went for full live and yeah i'd
encourage you all to
to take that risk as well
it was an incredibly dynamic and they
interacted with each other which was
really beautiful too
um and allowing that mix
like the panel panel model almost works
it's more
in this context because it's not just
one person talking but you can
jump off of each other
so before we um wrap up here i just i'm
gonna share this
last slide with everybody and i would
encourage you that you could take a
screenshot of this
and this is our information for space
for action
and if if you're interested in our
organization and and want to get
involved
um this is the information that you
would need to do so
so we're planning some hopefully
in-person events
when this is all over but definitely
some more virtual events until that
happens
and yeah we'd love to just engage more
people so
hit us up peter and tander thank you so
much this was such a wonderful workshop
um it was great to hear more about um
cease for action and i think it was
really an exciting conversation we can't
wait to
have more online events and then in
person very excited about that too
um and everyone please stick around arts
on the radar continues um so the act
gallery opening will be starting at five
um and we're thrilled about that as well
it's an exciting night
and thanks to susan lydia and shannon
rose for
you know helping put all this together
this is fun for us as well
thank you
you